so with this culture clash we can free
stars hello
TV episode we back again today we're
live in Brixton and for once gone Ghana
and Nigeria are gonna be friends to some
our country still
Oh deadest enough man our country is
still better our country is still safe
for we can write we can I can I was you
Chris what do you think the main
differences are but Africans and
Caribbean life if you could put up with
some [ __ ] random [ __ ] from menial [ __ ]
to anything just say anything and don't
think about to be in the proper cut
Nagi's are you yeah could you tell if
someone's African or Caribbean you know
I'd say your generation your your
growing up where storms in jail scene
took about Baumbach law and teaching
people about juju and stuff you know me
you know but I mean how many fool know
but it's odd but I'm just saying an
aside if you if you had a stellar and at
I ski next to each never ever heard
someone be I've heard more bad things
so what used to actually have the tub
with the Navy
when you wash yourself into so the main
differences between Africans in Jamaican
Jamaicans what would you say the main
difference is Rickey there you see
many things many things the way your
coach is completely different actually
like completely different completely
different in what you've seen in your
parents
you're in your heritage in your food in
your ideologies in what your parents
want from you ideally these are
basically the same I think I agree but I
think they've seen I think there's more
of a ferocious attack on what they want
and if there's not saying that her mom
just wanted her to be a doctor a lawyer
or a teacher she wanted she wanted to
work behind the scenes in sports and she
said that she had she had to in order to
make her mom proud in order to make her
mom diet daya proud woman she she went
and Donna teach in her teaching degree
worked as a teacher for X amount of
years got the thing to be a head teacher
and then her mom was proud and then
Sheila and she completely changed and
I'm done what she can do to me that's
[ __ ] lunacy but but because she fought
as normal because she had to make her
African mom proud to me that's
completely missing and that's just
because of how how I grew up
yeah does that does that makes an and
that is a stark difference I see you
mean it somber then I think is where
that comes from
I'd say come into this country and every
parent want every parent say like like
Caribbeans come here before so they seem
right there's other ways that you can
make other things you can do not
learning the culture that oh you know
what you can do they're just coming at
us we can draw I'm coming here to this
country coming later than and they don't
want and you know anything mediocre yeah
exactly
oh I didn't know that like that
footballers are gonna earn this much
money so you're playing football no no
you sure you better being in do your
homework you
and just one of the reason why we see
anything we think can go to tell your
parents I'm an indie music and go don't
you wanna be football which is because I
can relate to both him
you want to be a youtuber that's what he
quit to be a doctor injury injury by the
time was my turn but she died with you a
little carrot and she kind of said that
I think about it so that's where the
difference is I think back then now I
could have from the age of 18 I can
probably have a conversation about how
you need to talk in this year to be more
general because your mom's quite liberal
anyway different experience it's gonna
dilute the point so I think that's where
it's different I don't think I don't
think an African child could have that
conversation how do you feel then again
[Music]
we look back and be like oh why didn't
you when I say my cousin you know yeah
you know my mum would look back at like
oh this guy he's playful Indian Oh
oh they're in the back of Ben van Gogh
I'm gonna go quite deep yeah is that
Yugi you won't be the parents that you
had of course not no of course not
don't you think that there's something
in there that's what's happened there
why not
not that you should both have you
obviously like weight living some
clarity here you both have love in Paris
a and people look at me like you guys
have that that make our men but yeah
y-you had you had a brilliant I'm
bringing your parents gave you
everything that you wanted loving is
because you've just agreed to me that
you won't be the same parents yeah to
your children because I've seen the
world differently and I my mom and dad
come here and they were working seven
days a week cleaning school they had to
send they when I was born I was sent to
Ghana for a year to chew in my nanny and
my mum when you knit for her three years
finish uni was we you know me my brother
and sister were like pretty old and the
thing is there I think their whole thing
was they couldn't fail they like my kids
can't fail that and I'm not gonna give
them an opportunity where they might
silver spoon bomb saying now I feel like
I can't afford to be like if you want to
try that you can do you feel like they
were lot tougher but then because I look
at what my mum has done what she's built
up for all my family and I said I don't
think I could come over to a new country
at that age know myself now and done
what she 100 percent hundred business is
more it's harder now there's so much
harder now so I mean like the
president I'm not in the same ways but
the president my mom gave me for my 30s
I wish I could give that to one of my
kids by our pulley won't be able to buy
like he got he got a unicorn yeah
basically basically you know like are
you worried about the dilution of your
culture over the years from you having
kids and your kids and to you to show
your child the culture are you worried
that your great grandkids will be black
kids I'm not gonna be okay when you buy
a house is gonna be decorate how your
house is now when you when you get
married is gonna be like your house you
think [ __ ] Pentacles here in that in
there no my kids are gonna know they're
gonna know I'm gonna be going Ghana
every other year with my kids and
they're gonna be my sister leaves are
there they're gonna be seeing the odds
they're gonna be people going to speak
and treated him
I understand tree tree tree
the same argument because you're
listening to what's going on here hmm
well me to put to you you lost the plane
I said exactly I'm afraid of losing the
coach and I said I'm not afraid because
I know I'm gonna do my thing
exactly right so that's on you document
[Music]
question next question do you think
there's a stigma do you think there's a
stigma about African and Caribbean
and their treatment of women that's
great cuz ah speaking to and go about
this and she was saying stark
differences but I can't remember
actually cuz you know that I'm just
saying black men are now in the past
couple years I've been in black men has
been famous ain't been really remember
body with black men back derogatory
stereotypical if we go talk to girls cuz
I've never been yeah yeah but then but
then it could go back to the upbringing
and African man could have more
requirements of a wife or a girlfriend
then the Jamaica man would who do you
think treats women Bell African men
after men
Jamaica men who do you think treats
women better go on dope into that
no-good son my racist man cool I think
like to make him in a more notorious
having multiple baby mothers morning
yeah yeah no way now like like this
island here I've come in a more
monogamous I think so okay don't agree
but but is that is that is that the only
way to treat a woman bird - no young
African man
and then they cry anyway when I got the
passport any cop what do you think what
do you who do you think honestly because
there's so many ways you carry there
exactly did we say an African African
man you know I think both I think just
black men know a bit scary with women
yeah and especially because we've come
up we've come over to this to this
country not that long ago really in the
span of time yes that's one thing says
as black men go but I think like I
mentioned before how you guys are
brought up your expectancy and your
requirements and your criteria is higher
and almost quite prehistoric in terms of
like like some caveman [ __ ] like woman
cook woman
we're why don't we - my previous
generation suspect in getting someone
who's not in their culture yeah I think
I think a woman I think a woman is gonna
have more of a shot or culture shock
marrying an African man with him and his
family then marrying in and I'm not
saying that's bad bad or good I'm just
saying it will be more regiment oh I
said Africa mint tea and worse Geum was
no be you know be you mean OC you're
saying in terms of like the housework
and stuff yeah Robin oh yeah this is our
yard we'll both do it
alright babe I've got this number that's
the new world were in yeah no common
brood forget your minds like this talk
about stereotypical Jamaican we're
talking about you like being not
cheating this stuff like that that's
when you see when you say the devil in
terms of war they got them like on some
dog leash doing something because that's
all I'm saying
oh I think generation before us that's
how it's meant to be they that's how
they would say it's meant to be women
and men are do this we're minute you
know I mean it's only now that it's like
is 1559 there's one dude I work with
he's taking heed on half maternity leave
his wife got six months he goes yeah
they shared it and I was the first time
I ever heard
but that is the world it was always even
wingless when you get home let's be
serious Jamaica run is the smallest
island Jamaica run the world music
national team I'm seeing but look at
this I think everyone was anything has
changed no now because now everyone's
just seen as black now everyone's just
seen is black and then obviously like
now you can crack jokes in between each
other in school it was like
probably racist towards each other firm
yeah oh yeah yeah yeah she'd be cracking
but you'd laugh about absolutely telling
Jamaicans about themselves
Jamaica now I think you just seen this
black that everyone comes under that's a
but they're not saying all I see how we
go see us letter well that some might be
like nas either to make it now you know
what black men would be like I would
never be able to me now I think it's
just culture they see it they're like
you know what oh they're like the
Caribbean coach I like that I'm gonna be
going carnival with my mom wherever
African we go in Africa at Christmas let
me do that that's how I want to live I
think that's where is now it's the
culture look at the culture you're like
boom this another culture question did
whenever people had to come to your
heart did they have to say hello to mom
dad for anything just come on that James
is just comfortable seats ass even see
me if you come into my audience was the
youth club in it where man were just in
in a nothing I don't know where I grew
up that the kids are just not here and
say like I come in to get something
quickly alright 68 Ryan and he knows
your parents here they say he come in to
get something quickly and he popped in
and he popped out yeah or even if you do
something for 20 minutes and he just any
like your mom was in the city and she
saw him coming and come out he didn't
say she's not gonna bat an eyelid only
bi when I was rude she would
my one thing they wait they wait yeah I
recover questions because we are fool
you I felt what you said about Jamaica
be in this small island in this love run
[ __ ] run everything it's all that
basically patter that's just been made
in tonight more Road chap TV Bob you go
Big Brother everybody why why cuz we're
cool why does she answer it's not wear
cou what island countries like us we're
cool as [ __ ] I'm not even gonna say
Caribbean yeah it's Jamaica from
Jamaica's call music Jamaica from is you
could even name five Caribbean countries
yeah st. Vincent Jamaica Trinidad
Bahamas Barbados Barbados yeah well my
point is that you could name any any the
most famous person from each five of
them should a dad make Jamaican so it's
weirdly so weirdly special Island it's
so strange
no no in everything we go that's the
word that's the word Essen yeah yeah but
if you yeah all right if you could
package that it will be the
[ __ ] Richie Rich's place ever it's so
influential why I do not know by the end
of it they were all one and
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]